the gyro can experience so I was gonna
ask you how how's it been working with
Jimmy Smith I love that guy he's
brilliant he's brilliant he's a very
smart try to get him hired about four
years ago yeah and I was cuz the UFC was
looking for God first of all trying to
do less commentary because I'm
travelling too much and I was trying to
do last I was like you gotta hire this
guy he's the best yeah he's really
really smart
first we're doing our first show
together in April okay
the Tony Ferguson Habib number good
metafile good yeah Kabhi versus tony is
gonna be it's a perfect fight for you
know so whose color and play-by-play
then is he doing play-by-play
no John anacs doing okay by play and
John awesome both you in color yeah
we're just gonna have fun he's my friend
you know and he's been on the podcast a
bunch of times alright buddy so it'll be
yeah it'll be a good time and didn't he
cut his teeth doing a TV show about
combat sports yeah about he did I was
riding around the world or whatever
learning different arts was it called
fights aboard what was it call something
like that fight quest fight Wes oh yeah
it was yeah he did that but I mean I
think he's but he also had MMA fights
and he's a legit black belt in jujitsu
he's know he knows his stuff super smart
and well-read guy too
yeah I'm excited I'm excited that he's
on board yeah I always liked listening
to him
yeah Bellator [ __ ] up they [ __ ] up
and they left I couldn't I was wondering
what so well I'm not to pry but my guess
was he's just asked for more money
probably cuz he had an offer from the
UFC
they wouldn't match it so he well
whatever they didn't want him leaving
for the UFC four years ago when I tried
to get him higher right and there was
like a big hullabaloo and they wound up
keeping them and then I think his
contract was up and I think the way he
described it was they actually wanted to
give him less money and I was getting
and it's like I think they're just
experiencing some severe budget cuts
right if you think about Bella tours
market like what they're trying to do
they don't have a pay-per-view business
you know and if you don't have a
pay-per-view business where's the bulk
of all your money coming from it's a
kind of bleeding Viacom right I just
thought I just thought you know when it
happened I said why didn't they change
the name when Coker was brought in to
take over yeah it made zero sense to me
because Bellator had that
you know from Bjorn Rebney I've never
been a Bjorn Rebney fan during revenue
you know from that boxing promoter type
you know whatever it was and everybody
that I talked to in that in that
business they were all terrified and
intimidated and everything else is a lot
of [ __ ] yeah it was just I never met the
guy I don't know anything about him
other than the bad things that have
heard from fight right and so you know
King mo called him a dick Rider King mo
and I go back and forth we on the
internet on Facebook and stuff I I'll
deliberately piss him off on political
stuff and just get him stirred up is
underappreciated talent when it comes to
fighting ya know he's that guy was
monster physical problems though like
with mersa he had some serious staph
infection some real bad ones that
wrecked him mm-hmm
yeah that [ __ ] [ __ ] scare he's a
great guy though we talk we talk now and
then when I stop he is he's cool dude
and but God where were we we're talking
about but Alatorre should change the
name yeah it's just synonymous with
tournaments and a guy loses the title
and suddenly he's thrown back into a
tournament he's already made his name
yeah it's just a shitty business model
yeah Bellator was for the
spanish-speaking crowd right right that
what they were trying to get out of that
it's a Latin word right I think it's or
Roman word for gladiators and [ __ ] but
yeah it started out as wasn't unlike
ESPN Deportes or something yeah yeah it
just but it just didn't make sense with
kocher taken over and I I don't want to
watch the Geritol Posse fight that's how
they're doing I don't want to see a Pat
Miletich fight I don't want to see yeah
right you know yeah I love some of those
guys right but I don't want to watch it
it's you know it's a young man's sport
it's guys that are animals fast movers
just yeast invincible human beings in
their mid-20s to 30 whatever early 30s a
guy that's 45 years old is 45 but 45
years old with MMA miles on them yeah
that's the real issue right it's that
these guys their bodies have been beaten
up for so many decades in the gym and
all the years of wrestling and
kickboxing you know they're just not the
same no you know yeah it takes its toll
it definitely takes its toll and you're
just not you're just not the same I mean
it's part of me that respects
out of a guy like hoist Gracie he's
still a [ __ ] savage at 50 years of
age we're ready to throw down with that
anybody he wouldn't fight me
he wouldn't son of them when was this
I've been trying to I I i mean with
Bellator I said forget Gracie to fight
him well he was my shamrock I confronted
shamrock on access that was one of the
worst fights that I had was when Matt
beat the [ __ ] out of him Matt took his
back that was smashing him and I was
like Jesus Christ I was like this is
this is so mismatched
[Applause]